le ministre de l'Intérieur est arrivé ce
matin à jacciio Jean-Pierre Chevenement
demande au cors de se mobiliser pour
permettre à la vérité d'éclaté la
population est sous le choc atterré et
indigné Jacques Cardo Jean-François
georgetti geste inqualifiable semble
dire cet homme au petit jour l'ambiance
est lourde pesante c'est le représentant
de la République qui a été abattu hier
soir et ce matin tous ont le visage
grave émil zuouukarelli première
personnalité à se rendre au chevet du
défunt d'un homme qu'il connaisse un
homme direct et justement
sans d'un abord d'un abord
facile se
déplaçant je dirais
aisment bien vu sans requérir de
protection particulière mais l'émotion
la plus forte la plus palpable en tout
cas est dans la rue des fleurs et des
mots pour témoigner ici un registre de
condoléance a été ouvert je voulais dire
tous mes regrets pour le peuple corse
pour ce qu'on représente parce que je
suis CORSE avant tout je suis né ici
j'ai toujours vécu ici et ça ça ne se
fait pas c'est pas de chez nous bien s
ça me choque fait la prière fois en ça
on devient pire
Tex par la colère par l'émotion les
corps s'expriment un peu de leur
écœurement oui il s'agit d'un ave
d'impuissance le représentant à
l'Assemblée de cor on entend c'est vrai
souvent les mêm
et tous les responsables politiques
administratif tiennent toujours le même
propos mais quand on a atteint le
paroxisme il n'y a sans doute autre
chose à faire et de
l'état j'attends sa détermination et de
notre communauté j'attends une
manifestation de dignité et
d'espérance toujours la même litanie
toujours le même scénario au lendemain
d'un tel événement renfort de police
dans les les rues de la ville bientôt
dans toute la Corse avec l'arrivée du
GPN pendant ce temps le ministre de
l'Intérieur réclame l'aide de toute la
population je voudrais demander à tous
nos concitoyens de nous aider pour faire
la vérité car un homme est mort c'est
celui qui représentait la République en
Corse et il était abattu dans les
conditions de l'acheter je crois qu'il
en va de l'avenir de la Corse si nous
voulons pas sombrer dans une régression
barbare en attendant les prog quête le
Premier ministre Lionel Jospin est venu
lui aussi témoigner de son émotion
auprès de la famille du défunt clôurant
ainsi une matinée de
deuil